[Musique]
Madame Mademoiselle
Monsieur depuis le début de cette
campagne les candidats vous ont présenté
programme
mesure
promesse c'est
normal personnellement vendredi prochain
à la télévision je prendrai des
engagements sur la nouvelle société des
engagements
précis concernant toutes les catégories
sociales le 5
mai il s'agira du destin de la
France de sa
jeunesse
de la condition
humaine et qui pourrait en parler mieux
qu'André
mer comme je vais vous parler de l'une
des tâches les plus hautes que puisse
assumer la
France je tiens à préciser d'abord que
si vous choisissez que nous
l'entreprenions ensemble je ne serit en
aucun cas parlementaire ni
candidat
à quoi assistonsnous depuis le début de
la campagne
électorale les candidats sont obligés de
traiter de ce que nous pourrions appeler
l'ensemble des problèmes et en
particulier des problèmes de
gestion c'est fait avec de petites
différences un peu
plus à droite avec Monsieur Giscard
destin un peu plus dans dans l'extrême
gauche enfin dans l'extrême gauche
moyenne avec Monsieur mitteran et au
centre par Jacques Chaban
Delm il s'agit naturellement d'autres
choses lorsque j'ai eu affaire à la
télévision j'avais reçu d'une petite
commune une lettre signée depuis les
notables notaire médecin jusqu'à une
femme qui signait celle qui tient la
cantine c'est à ce village que je
m'adresse car il me disait et qu'est-ce
que nous pourrions faire pour que la
France redevienne la
France il y a un problème qui se pose à
nous d'une façon immédiate avant M le
problème du travail c'est celui de la
jeunesse il couvre le monde il seppose à
San Francisco comme il seose au Japon en
Hollande comme à Paris or il est
possible de le résoudre il est possible
de changer complètement les conditions
de
l'enseignement en remplassant presque
intégralement le livre par la télévision
le livre demeurant pour son utilisation
lorsque l'enfant est chez lui nous
pouvons changer les conditions de la
jeunesse et les conditions de la vie le
plan est trop complexe pour que je
puisse l'exposer complètement disons il
est le lien entre l'utilisation
permanente de la télévision et
l'utilisation de
l'ordinateur il n'est pas chimérique et
il cou
le
10e de l'emprunt qui est actuellement
prévu par tous les
candidats quoi qu'il
arrive ce cette transformation aura
lieu les choses qui doivent arriver dans
l'humanité lorsqu'elles sont liées à la
technique si on ne les trouve pas
quelque part on les trouve ailleurs nous
pouvons changer l'enseignement dans le
monde en le changeant chez nous si nous
décidons de le faire et autrement nous
le ferons quand même mais nous le ferons
dans 10 ans à la remorque des autres
rendez-vous bien compte que ça veut dire
pour les enfants s'amuser au lieu de
s'ennuyer ça veut dire pour les
adultes trouver le droit de qui
la salle où la télévision parle
d'histoire pour celle où elle parle de
physique et si nous parlons comme nous
le faisons beaucoup de liberté et bien
cette fois nous en parlerons
véritablement avec un sens
concret bien entendu il ne s'agit pas de
demander au plus grands esprits de venir
exposer leur thèse Einstein m'avait dit
en me montrant
un livre publié sur lui par un
journaliste et dont lui avait fait la
préface pour en montrer sérieux si on
veut que les gens comprennent mes idées
il ne faut pas qu'ils me liseent il faut
qu'il liseent ce livre donc
l'enseignement dont nous parlons serait
donné par les meilleurs pédagogues pas
nécessairement par les meilleur
chercheurs enfin il ne s'agit pas de
supprimer le corps en enseignant il
s'agit de lui redonner sa fonction la
plus
noble il serait là pour aider ceux qui
ont besoin d'être aidés c'est pourquoi
on avait conçu le corps
enseignant pourquoi
penser que un tel
plan peut attendre beaucoup plus de
Chavan Delm que d'un autre
d'abord parce qu'il s'y est attaché
ensuite parce que du moment que les
gouvernements de l'Est ne l'ont pas
élaboré ou pas
acceptter je dis que les tenant du
programme commun ne l'exécuteront pas et
enfin parce
que vous les gens du village qui
m'écoutiez qui m'avez écrit vous savez
que l'homme qui vous a enseigné la
lecture qui vous a fait ce que vous êtes
c'est Jul ferry et que Jul fée ne peut
pas être représenté par la
droite j'ai confiance aussi en Jacques
chavandmas pour une autre
raison nous avons combattu
ensemble il y a 30
ans je sais ce qu'il souhaite je connais
son
énergie et enfin je le répète il est le
seul qui le fera parce qu'il est le seul
qui est dès maintenant envie de le faire
oui je le
ferai et je le
feraiis comme avec le général de
Gaulle nous avons toujours
fait ce que nous devions
faire